all right a couple days ago a buddy sent  this thing to me and I didn't do one of  these on it at the time because I wanted  to look into it to find out if it's  legit and everyone online including but  not limited to the guy who sent it to  the guy who sent it to me they swear  that it's actually a survey from Crystal  Dynamics and it surveys fans of legacy  of Kane about Legacy of Kane like what  did you like about Legacy of Kane what  do you remember what do you want to see  in the future do you want to see a  remaster a retelling a remake do you  want to see a sequel It's like  there's Legacy of cane interest from  Crystal Dynamics we're going back to NAS  God the dude this needs to happen my  fellow nazgothians  if this is gonna happen  they should get Amy Hennig back to  direct because Legacy of Kane is her  Legacy